Aww yeah! Let's learn English with
everyone's favorite Disney superhero family,
The Incredibles!
So Disney animations in general
are fantastic for learning English.
And, this scene in particular is absolutely
packed with useful vocabulary for you to study.
Now, we'll see in this scene that Elastigirl,
whose real name is Helen,
is visiting the stylist Edna Mode.
Now, stylists are professionals who design
clothing, and in Edna's case,
she also designs suits for superheroes
like the ones that we'll see in the scene.
Let's roll it!
Hey! Do you want to improve your vocabulary,
and master American pronunciation
so that you can confidently understand
fast-speaking natives?
Well, we've got a fun and powerful way
for you to do it
with our Fluent with Friends course.
This course will take you on an adventure
learning English with the TV series Friends,
which is highly regarded not only as
one of the best TV series of all time,
but, also one of the best to learn English with.
Every week, you get PDF Power Lessons,
vocabulary memorization software,
and so much more.
Plus, you will never be alone in your learning
because you'll also get access to
our global community of learners
from all over the world, the Fluency Circle.
The best part is: you can try that all for FREE right now
now with our 3-part Masterclass.
All you have to do is click up here, or down
in the description below to learn more and sign up.
And we're really looking forward
to meeting you inside.
Hey! If you think that this lesson is incredible,
then, after you finish it,
you better check out this playlist,
where you can learn with more Disney movies.
Just click up here, or down in the description below,
to find that after you finish the video.